[Musique]
merci de nous retrouver nos envies de
lecture si comme vous êtes passionné de
lecture serait ravi de retrouver leur
rang bonjour et stéphanie bonjour
isabelle tous les deux toujours libre à
la librairie du pavé du canard c'est cet
avis du canal oui tout à fait alors une
sélection aujourd'hui à ses fins oui
c'est donc à ces politiques aussi en
actes oui par asli erdogan est la poupée
alors on a une marianne maji alors
qu'ils aient marque c'est la boule paix
et la littérature d'une iranienne
une toute jeune iranienne qui est qui
est née la baronnie roncq il ya 24 ans
qui a 6 ans a dû être exfiltré de son
pays qui est encore pleine rémission
d'une révolution et avec comme unique et
m arrêter là bas et donc c'est une
histoire en fait on peut le prendre
comme un conte de fées aussi sur chaque
chapitre commence par il était une fois
donc c'est ça qui est très beau aussi
dans ses bouquins puisque à la rentrée
on a eu des orientales jeunes qui
traitait aussi de ce sujet là mais cette
fois ci c'est voilà c'est ce côté
enfantin peu un peu de comptes qui nous
transportent les qui nous raconte cette
belle histoire d'enfant en fait qui a
vécu avec des parents qui étaient
résistants alors le titre pourquoi marc
c'est pourquoi la poupée en fait parce
que ses parents était marxiste dont la
résistance vraiment très actif
son nom qui a été incarcéré et torturé
et donc forcément mart et la couper
parce qu'en fait ses parents avant de
partir d'hier en mai on dit battu à
donner tout est joué aux enfants parce
qu'elle a vécue comme en vrai des champs
dans la légalité et donc elle a dû donc
quitter tout s'est joué tout son
environnement et donc on a exfiltré
vraiment de façon très violente de ce
pays pour une intégration très difficile
et pour une fois on met le perse donc la
langue perse
donc au départ elle a voulu totalement
refusé cette mon plein natale et après
les revenus petit à petit et c'est ce
retour à la langue natale qui a permis
aussi de de s'enraciner avec l'afrique
de se reconstruire tout à fait pourquoi
pas le thème de la perte
c'est ça de la perte de la renaissance
en fait l'idée de la vraie renaissance
est en fait c'est un roman
autobiographique
donc c'est une vraie personne et qui a
vécu ces événements là et en plus c'est
une prof de français d'autant plus donc
cette histoire de la langue c'est
vraiment très fort chez elles peuvent
que ce soit le père comme le français
parce que c'est devenu une prof de
français dans des endroits un peu
difficile en france et donc maintenant
elle et elle écrit des livres son tout
premier roman
elle vit en france soit tout à fait sur
un blog
accary un peu enfin on espère la voir à
la librairie mais novice et une
française très bien est ce que vous
voulez a enchaîné votre silence n'est
plus à coiffe d'hassli erdogan alors qui
est une ancienne scientifique qui est
devenu journaliste qui est turc
alors cet été lors du tout je rate et on
en a beaucoup parlé d'eux en juillet
tout à fait surtout en ce moment là il
ya le procès des putschistes qui sont
qui allure ces jours-ci donc ça d'autant
plus de résonance c'est une journaliste
qui a été emprisonné pour ses récits
qu'elle tenait dans un journal procure
donc on l'emprisonné on l'a libéré toute
fin décembre la met donc là c'est un
récit de 39 texte qu'elle a fait dans
certains cas justement faisait
pièces à conviction c'est ça c'était des
essais des pièces à conviction de pour
son fameux procès et son emprisonnement
faisait s'appuyer sur ces textes là et
c'est alors c'est pas juste des textes
et ne sait des textes pleins de poésie
en fait c'est ça qui est beau aussi
c'est que c'est une personne qui s'est
toujours battu pour la liberté
d'expression mais qui est empreinte de
deux belles poésies vraiment c'est une
très belle plus et on voit là également
non moi je n'ai pas lu moi j'ai suivi
effectivement à lola torrente à cet été
cette affaire voilà fusion il ya une
forte mobilisation internationale
effectivement il le faire effectivement
les sorties conditions auxquelles est un
peu devenu en quelque sorte de symbole
d'une liberté d'expression bafouée dans
la turquie d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai
enfin c'est quand même une fenêtre
finalement qui restent ouvertes c'est ça
qui aussi qui est très optimiste c'est
finalement on a quand même réussi à la
faire sortir et que d'arrêter des gens
pour ses idées voilà on a aussi compris
que il fallait que ça cesse donc voilà
c'est une très très beau livre vraiment
magnifique
alors de quoi parle alors moi c'est un
tout autre registre romand s'était fait
ce que l'on avait des autobiographies
donc là c'est du roman
là c'est vraiment du roman alors peter
je t'aime je crois qu'on dit je t'aime
c'est un auteur allemand donc c'est pas
son premier livre en tout cas moi c'est
le premier camp jeudi de lui voilà
l'autre l'histoire d'un couple qui
rentrent de vacances on est en suisse
il arrange les affaires ils couchent les
enfants le profit tous les deux
tranquillement cette soirée un peu on a
au mois d'août voilà rien les enfants
qui couine donc à demande pour aller
voir et puis lui pendant ce temps là
mais bien ils sont vingt ans alors il
n'est pas drôle drôle parce qu'en fait
ils ne fuient pas on sent que le couple
est heureux on sent quelque chose mais
lui il s'en va ll va se pencher
lendemain c'est la rentrée elle est déjà
dans le quotidien bon il n'est pas là
mais elle se dit qu'elle n'a pas entendu
ce coucher ni entendu se lever tôt pour
partir travailler donc voilà il
s'inquiète pas outre mesure
finalement il ya quelques temps un petit
peu à s'inquiéter à dire finalement il
est vraiment parti et le roman donc
alterne entre son récit à lui qui avance
lui s'en va les deux points de vue à
l'aller 2 points de vue et elle qui au
départ n'y fait
elle appelle la secrétaire pour dire que
vahid est malade elle appelle pas glam
et il est juste malade on va aller voir
le médecin et cetera et c'est finalement
au bout de quelques temps elle va à la
police pour dire ben voilà il
les parisiens aiguillon le suivent dans
sa vie de vagabondage ce spleen ils
s'organisent pour survivre dans la
nature
voilà donc tout le roman c'est en suisse
et de ces deux récits parallèles ils
vivent pas du tout la même chose
l'un l'autre on sent pas du tout une
haine l'un envers l'autre on ne comprend
pas effectivement ce qui se passe là
même à la fin on allait voir casser il
ya plusieurs explications à ce très
drôle parce que j'en ai parlé justement
avec le représentant qu'on a que j'ai vu
ce matin et à midi et toi tu penses quoi
alors parce qu'elle me dit mais selon
les lecteurs sont les libraires qui
l'ont lu il ya différentes probabilité
de pourquoi j'en ai une aile en a une
autre voie là aussi bien de finalement
non moi je trouve pas que ce soit si
explicite que ça mais on pense aussi
beaucoup moins simple on sait aussi au
féminin au phénomène est évaporée qui
vient au lard beaucoup au japon
voilà des gens qui aident à prédire et
qui disparaissent font le choix vraiment
mais c'est un choix volontaire nous
paraît alors pour des raisons
financières pour des raisons alors c'est
beaucoup mais alors beaucoup phase aller
mais est en france mais également lors
je ne connais pas la proportion je
connais pas les chiffres mais il ya
aussi des gens qui vont qui seront soit
de laisser cette idée aussi qu'on
connaît jamais complètement vraiment
l'autre voilà il ya ça aussi et c'est
vrai que dans livre parce que le coup il
ya beaucoup de choses sur le couple sur
la vie à deux est sûre finalement voilà
qu'est ce qu'on connaît vraiment de
l'autre qu'est ce qu'on connaît vraiment
de la vie à deux voilà à quoi on
s'attendait
et finalement qu'est ce que pensent
véritablement l'autre c'est pas c'est
pas un livre plombant tellement que
j'allais me demandais quand même parce
que c'est pas vrai c'est pas
efficacement joyeux ça j'en conviens il
est destin lui paraissait pas tant qu'il
est à leurs yeux ce qui déstabilisa
parce que enfin gérant club des portes
on s'en va parce qu'il ya eu une grosse
dispute parce qu'on en a marre est ce
qu'on savait plus parce que leur honneur
il n'y a pas de
et du coup c'est ça qui est perturbant
mais ce communication à la fin une
explication sur leur sort que
scientifique il faut voilà ce qu'on
attend des explications à tout à oui
quand même ce sujet comme ça je pense
qu'il va sûrement pas oui mais il tu
aurais toi une version à la lecture du
roman il ya quand même une fin et quand
même quelque chose et tu aurel croit une
version voilà qui serait pas forcément
la mienne ou celle d'isabelle scénarisé
voilà ce qui est intéressant je suis
moins de voir toi je mens comment tu
comment tu le plus joli et comment tu la
vois cette double bras duo cette origine
jamais complètement et c'est très très
bien fait on arrive à passer de l'un à
l'autre
oui parce qu'à chaque fois ça s'enchaîne
de façon très originale comme si
finalement le ces deux personnages
finalement il y en a presque qu'un pont
kor quelque part très bien et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très très bien
c'est pas plombante énorme un très bon
bouquin allez on vous voilà merci
stéphanie on continue avec avec ce livre
jeu de miroirs jeu de miroirs écrit par
un alors je crois qu'on prononce qui ont
vite chi qui est un écrit en 2001 il est
roumain mais le roman est traduit de
l'américain d'accord non qui est le
roman événement ses fruits ça c'est des
raisons marketing qui excusez moi
monsieur l'éditeur ces voix là mais
effectivement c'est un roman qui a fait
beaucoup beaucoup de bruit gros buzz
internet il joue beaucoup et il est
traduit dans beaucoup beaucoup de
langues et effectivement quand je vais
faire refermer
on pense beaucoup aussi à la faire
arrêter baer qui étaient épars dicaire
s'est excellemment bien fait c'est entre
c'est pas vraiment un roman policier en
soit on pas du tout mais c'est un roman
baisses d'impôts l'insee non moi je
dirai pas ce que ça va pas vraiment la
trame classique d'un polar
histoire d'un l'huile c'est un éditeur
un éditeur qui reçoit un jour un
manuscrit
donc on lit avec lui le manuscrit et le
manuscrit révèlerait en fait
l'assassinât qui n'a jamais été élucidé
il ya une vingtaine ou trentaine
d'années d'un grand professeur en
psychologie et a priori ce manuscrit va
révéler ce qui s'est vraiment passé il
ya 30 ans sauf que bien évidemment ça se
termine avon et le l'auteur de ce
manuscrit
si vous êtes intéressé à pour publier ce
livre là je vous donnerai la seconde
partie où vous effectivement donc
l'agent littéraire fait des pieds et des
mains pour essayer de retrouver cette
deuxième partie qui est introuvable
l'auteur est décédé entre-temps tessin
cedex la nette correction alors s'il ya
eu fin quand même mais ce qui est très
original c'est justement comment l'en
quête ou comment le oui l'anc est
vraiment et menez se sait il ya un
journaliste qui va également l'aider il
ya plusieurs personnes qui vont comme ça
intervenir dans le roman et ce qui est à
moi ce qui m'a plu c'est dès le titre
dit beaucoup ces jeux de miroirs jeux de
mémoire au jeu de vérité en fait reste
chacun a sa propre c'est la thématique
de la recherche de la vérité
tout à fait et du coup chacun a sa
version et nous lecteurs on se dit mais
finalement quelle est la bonne version
est jusqu'à la fin on doute
et du coup je pense que c'est ça qui
fait que c'est le roman événement et que
c'est un roman ce camp m haies en fait
dans ce suspense on fait tout à fait
pipi comme il ya plusieurs versions
on se dit mais finalement la quelle est
la bonne là rien n'a pas vu une de
bouquins hemingway est très très bien
fait c'est même comme un peuple mythique
cirque on n'a pas envie effectivement je
les lis pas ce qu'on écrit
voilà laurent labit non je n'ai pas vu
cela à la fin oui même si beaucoup
d'enfants malades il ya une vraie vraie
fin on serre c'est vraiment ça ça vaut
ça mérite ce set
oui je pense 6 à 10 est comment dire ça
effectivement le roman et le roman
événement ce phénomène fins illégales
local est un phénomène et c'est là je
n'ai pas s'il a vraiment ce besoin de ce
côté là mais oui c'est un très bon livre
et qui effectue les siens d'atteindre
gonesse je crois que c'est son premier
livre ballaro c'est vraiment son premier
1000 lacs en fait une maison d'édition
qui qui est très chouette ça paie les
escales qui édite peu de romans mais
toujours des petites pépites comme ça il
ya au moins un ou deux livres qui est
que l'on remarque et qui sont en général
de bonne facture tout à fait d'accord
d'autres coups de coeur dans l'actualité
d'autres plus tôt hommage ou quelque
chose que nous la main à dire peut-être
alors moi c'est les freakonomics comme
sorti un troisième opus là en économie
comme ça ça paraît pas sa paresse et
austère mais là c'est plus du
développement personnel vu par des
économistes dont qui prennent plein de
tout de la vie actuelle et qui
décortique un peu et comment on peut
avoir un angle de vision un peu décalé
il nous permet de résoudre pas mal de
soucis ça s'appelle freakonomics
économique
deux économistes américains
ok voilà merci à tous les deux très bien
[Musique]